le cinéma et nous partons pour cannes
avec la présentation pour la clôture
demain du film de christophe honoré les
bien-aimés est avec nous ce soir trois
femmes trois comédiennes qui partagent
l'affiché
catherine deneuve chiara mastroianni et
ludivine sagnier bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous avant de parler cinéma
une petite parenthèse catherine deneuve
d'abord un mot de l'actualité forte
quelle est votre réaction face à cette
affaire dominique strauss kahn
ah mais vous étiez me cueillir à froid
comme ça je m'attendais pas du tout à
cette question moi je suis très choquée
je suis très choqué de la de
l'hypocrisie de gens qui se plaignent
vraiment de la façon dont on montre des
choses aussi dégradantes et on les
montre en boucle à la télévision je
trouve ça extrêmement choquant quoi
qu'il soit arrivé je trouve ça
extrêmement choquant voilà la réaction
puisque c'est ce que vous et moi car
elle donne à vous me parliez il ya
quelques mois de ce film et bien voilà
nous y sommes à la mairie voulait mais
parce qu'ils parlent d'amour parce que
c'est christophe honoré parce que nous y
chantait ou parce que vous jouez avec
les deux femmes qui sont à côté de vous
mais pour toutes ces raisons
franchement pour toutes ces raisons
parce que ça tu appelles les bien-aimés
parce qu'on ne parle que d'amour parce
qu on y chante aussi l'amour parce que
voilà l'amour entraîne à la fois du des
moments de bonheur mais aussi aussi des
tristesses des chagrins et voilà et
christophe honoré et ludivine et karaba
soyez ni voilà c'était quelque chose de
très exaltant pour moi alors de la danse
des chansons une réalisation soignée
bref les règles d'or de christophe
honoré sont respectés à quoi ressemble
bien aimé on regarde cela avec abdellah
mostefa et mathieu dreujou on se
retrouve juste après
c'est en france un mois
oui
70 me le divine sagnier madeleine dans
les années 60
sur la route en l'escalier maman calcul
est son potentiel chiffre d'affaires ses
calculettes ou les escarpins nude toutes
les robes qu'elles allaient désormais
pouvoir s'acheter chiara mastroianni et
verra la fille de mme athènes dans les
années 90 et 2000
dans ces mêmes années la mère de vera
est interprétée par catherine deneuve
trois actrices d'expérience pour jouer
mères et filles à travers les décennies
passent à elles deux débutants tétanisé
milos forman et michel delpech
mais le réalisateur pouvait compter sur
catherine deneuve c'est ça qui est très
agréable en fait avec catherine c'est
que elle une sorte de relais en fait
pour le metteur en scène c'est à dire
qu'elle rassure énormément les autres
comédiens et et après c'était assez
drôle de la voir après chaque prise en
fait sculpter avec milos et michel ont
raté formidable qu'est ce que tu fais là
tu peux rentrer de moore pas patient
subit mais un script madeleine retrouve
son premier amour dans l'appartement de
sa fille avant de retrouver son actuel
mari en province une valse des
sentiments qui se traduit aussi en
chansons mais voilà mon coeur
cette légèreté m'abandonne catherine
deneuve dans une comédie musicale
joli clin d'oeil à la filiation assumé
de christophe honoré à jacques demy
sentimentale et léger c'est bien aimé
seront bienvenues pour clôturer un
festival de cannes à la sélection
souvent noir est grave
dimon
alors cammas oriani vous êtes vraiment
fidèle à christophe honoré et
inversement
oui j'allais vous dire justement vous
m'enlevez les mots de la bouche allez
vous dira plutôt inversement j'ai
beaucoup de chance
en même temps vous allez la fidélité
c'est terrible parce qu'on veut y aller
un moment où ça va ça va bouger quoi
mais pour l'instant je profite et je ne
désespère pas que de retravailler encore
écrit store ça c'est pour te mettre un
peu la pression d'un déficit très ravi
cette fois ils vous proposent dit d'elle
et il vous a proposé en fait de vous
retrouver aux côtés de votre mère
sincèrement est-ce que ça vous a apporté
de la légèreté ou une pression
particulière non la pression'' ans parce
que comme on se connaît il n'y a pas la
peur qu'on pourrait avoir quand on
tourne avec catherine deneuve ça me fait
bizarre de dire le nom comme si on était
à la mairie mais s'appelle pas comme ça
mais donc non pas une pâle peuvent pas
du tout une pression moi pour moi la
pression c'est juste ne pas décevoir le
metteur en scène
alors il s'agit d'une fraise qui
commence en 1964 ludivine sagnier c'est
avec vous tout commence vous avez une
passion pour les escarpins vous marchez
dans la rue et vous vous arrêtez et
votre vie bascule oui ma vie parce que
parce que deux au début du film je suis
vendeuse dans un magasin de chaussures
ayant cette passion pour les escarpins
jean chypre régulièrement et un moment
où je suis en train de maintenir et dans
le miroir un homme propose de de monter
avec lui pour de l'argent et ses lacs
que ma vie change et prend une tournure
un peu plus déviante qu'elle n'y
paraissait on vous entend chanter ce un
vrai plaisir dans ce cinéma d'honoré
justement c'est à la fois intimes léger
et enchante
oui j'avais déjà eu ce plaisir là écart
est également pour les chansons d'amour
donc on n'avait plus la peur
d'appréhender ce mélange textes et
chansons
donc je pense qu'on a on a un prix
encore plus de plaisir
cette fois ci à mélanger les deux et
puis c'est quelque chose de naturel pour
les acteurs de chanter ça nous fait tout
ça très justement catherine deneuve dans
l'une des chansons que l'on entend dans
le film il ya ces mots les filles
légères ont le coeur lourd
il est bien difficile de poser une règle
idéale en matière d'amour vous l'avez
dit légère ou sérieuses vous avez fini
par faire un choix ou pas non pas
vraiment parce que je pense que en amour
on subit beaucoup je pense que les
sentiments que l'on porte à quelqu'un
après on est emporté justement par ses
sentiments et c'est très difficile de
garder raison ou même de penser qu'on a
un jugement on est vraiment porter ces
très violents l'amour
chiara mastroianni cannes c'est
finalement les jets ou sérieux ça dépend
des années ou des jours c'est à dire que
là évidemment comme nous ne sommes pas
en compétition n'y a pas là il n'y a pas
la pression langoat m'enfin y'a quand
même le trac de montrer le film moi je
suis très heureuse de le voir sur cet
écran 3 quels sont les super grand
francs et puis très belle salle très
belle salle et puis donc du coup voilà
c'est assez marrant on arrive là à la
fin et c'est beaucoup plus calme
moi qui suis toujours en train de dire
je
je suis très angoissé cette fois je peux
pas vous dire ça parce que ça va mais il
ya quand même un petit peu de trac
toujours mais ça va bon en tout cas ne
le soyez pas ça très joli film j'aurais
aimé rester plus longtemps avec vous
mais vous le savez le temps est compté
dans l'ailleurs et bien sûr parler
d'amour demande plus de temps en tout
cas en général
merci beaucoup d images des comédiennes
des mélodies des mots je rêve dans la
nuit qui avance et l'amour dans tous ses
états donc c'est à voir c'est les bien
aimés c'est christophe honoré